I have something for you mommy your dad
this rings him back right back to life
the fill on wood is a tale of two
brothers trying to finally meet their
father I'm gonna meet dad they perform
this spell which will hopefully bring
their dad back it's a pretty great
concept that has so much hard
dad just Oh top part and that's exactly
exert does so well we've only got 24
hours to bring back the rest of dad when
Chris got the role he called Tom and
said I'm your brother this is so fun Tom
it is fun the best part of the job was
the fact I got to do my buddy Chris for
any spell to work you have to speak from
your hearts fire our hearts fire I love
these two whippersnappers and as the
mother of two teenage boys I have that
in common with Laurel because that's
been the joy of my life now take out the
trash family is important I'm looking
for my sons
oh they went on a quest but don't worry
I told them about the map I told them
about the gym I told them about the
curse what this definitely pulls at the
heartstrings I just want to meet you
that's why I love Pixar movies you
always walk away feeling like you've
been a part of something real
Pixar and we're really encouraged to
tell personal stories my father passed
away when I was a year old so when
you're making a personal story you get
to delve into something that's real and
encouraging for other people you can do
this
I'm cleaning you it's moving because
it's rooted in real relationships and
that's the fun of making one of these
movies is at some point it's the story
of all the people who helped make it and
then it becomes the story of all the
people who watch it
[Music]